with the elections over the start of a
new chapter at the Parliament openly 751
returning and newly elected mep s find
their feet on the first few days they
will be even half my time with us it
quits they will go first downstairs with
all the linguistic stands are and they
will be helped to fill all the
application forms on induction day we
come up with some of the new recruits
I'm looking to work on the transport
committee and in the effect committee
I'm a lawyer so i will choose some
Commission where I can do something give
some proposition for a new European
legislation it's really exciting I mean
I'm the first MEP from the southwest of
England from the Green Party so it's
just brilliant to be here and I'm really
looking forward to finding out what kind
of contribution i can make Molly caused
an upset squeezing past liberal stalwart
Graham Watson as it was our first day we
also gave her a bit of a guided tour
okay so this is one of the biggest
committee rooms are probably you'll be
having lots of meetings in you know
you're not going to be intimidated by
furniture how are you when you're
thinking about climate change a former
economist what I her big plans for the
years ahead I've put my name down for
econ I hope that'll be successful and
I'm also hoping to work on the
agricultural side because obviously the
southwest is a strong agricultural
region so that's going to be a priority
for me as well the new term gets under
way on July the first and just like the
rest of the new recruit Molly has a busy
few weeks ahead new country new job new
office new alliances lots to do and it
all starts here